Really fun.
You got into the mega makeover action today.
Oh yes, I did.
(audience laughing)
Okay, well you transformed one of our teachers,
Gregory Marie, and during the pandemic,
I am so proud to announce that he lost 60 pounds,
(audience applauding)
which is such
an incredible feat.
So this was Gregory before,
and this is Gregory now.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Greg.
Yeah.
Come on. I love it.
Gregory.
You look so handsome,
but I really believe all beauty is a feeling.
How do you feel?
I feel amazing.
After having lost all that weight,
it has been feel so good just to be here,
and just to be experiencing this entire thing.
Okay, in a nutshell, how did you do it?
My sister-in-law.
She inspired me.
She found a great program,
and I was able to adapt it, and just go from there.
I'm like, "What program?"
(audience laughing)
We're all trying to get higher and tighter.
What'd you do?
Well, it was called Healthy You,
and it was just a lot of like intermittent fasting
and things like that.
Oh, that damn intermittent fasting.
(audience laughing)
So it does work.
Mm-hmm.
Wow, Gregory.
Well, you are living walking proof of a true...
Well done.
(audience applauding)
Discipline and transformation.
Now, Wilmer, will you explain what you did
with sir handsome, Gregory?
The thing that is important is,
just focus on solid colors first.
Start there, before you introduce patterns, right?
Then when you go to the level of difficulty,
then introduce your patterns, you know,
but I think it's important that you go,
okay, listen, warm colors together, cold colors together.
You know?
And when I was thinking about,
it was that the way that he carries himself,
the sneakers that he likes to wear, he likes comfort.
You like comfort.
So it was like, just focus more on your sneakers
and dress backwards.
What shoes do you wanna wear?
And then pair the pants with those.
Right?
Or pair the top with those. Right?
But one or the other, I think, right.
Gregory, your mom and dad, John and Anna,
are here in the audience.
Hello.
Hi.
(audience applauding)
I'd love to hear from both of you
how you feel about Gregory's transformation.
We are so, so very proud of him.
It was a, it was a journey,
and he stuck with it, and he's a dedicated person,
and that's why he was also recognized
as Teacher of the Year, too.
(audience applauding)
And Gregory, as a teacher,
can you give us one piece of wisdom,
as if we are all your students,
as we go to commercial break?
What would you impart on all of us?
The importance of being kind,
and always try and think about how everyone else may feel
when you're dealing with someone else.
I agree,
(audience applauding)
though it goes back to the feeling again.
Well, Wilmer, you have been someone, as I said before,
full circle, who has always made us feel so good,
whether it's through your art or your humor
or your humanity, and so thank you so much for coming here
and being a part of this very special show.
Always happy. Thank you.
As you are such a special person.
(audience applauding)
Thank you for inviting me.
Thank you. Come back.
So nice to see you.
Nice to meet you. Thank you, thank you.
Always around.
Ditto. Ditto.
Well you can watch Wilmer on "NCIS",
Mondays at 9:00 PM, Eastern, right here on CBS.
(upbeat music)